aber wissen Sie wie viele Niederländer
im Jahr sterben weil sie bekifft mit
zusteine Treppe runterfallen nein ich
würde tippen null
während Lutz sich auf einer Baustelle in
Deutschland umsieht fahre ich in die
Niederlande hier wird gebaut gebaut und
gebaut und Wohnungen errichten sie auch
erster kiffer-gag Check dann kann es ja
losgehen
amster ich treffe den deutschen
Architekten Matthias Rottmann ein super
intelligenter Typ was man daran erkennt
dass er eben in Holland arbeitet und
nicht in Deutschland in Deutschland war
2021 Neubau 18 % teurer als in den
Niederlanden gibt's da Beispiele wo man
das alles einspart ähm das sind viele
kleine Details aber sind auch ein paar
wichtige berufliche Fragen das eine z.B
wie er schließlich ein Gebäude von innen
mit einem Treppenhaus oder mit einem
Laubengang und wir haben hier ein
Beispiel ja das ist nicht ein ganz
klassischer Laubengang aber da oben gibt
so eine Brücke und hier vorne sind wir
vorhin drüber gelaufen auch noch eine
und die sind eigentlich dafür da und um
in dem Gebäude das Treppenhaus zu sparen
und dann geht man ins andere rüber und
dann erst runter das mögen ja auch viele
Holländer weil man dann auch so ein
Plausch mit dem Nachbarn direkt teilen
kann ja nicht die späteren Bewohner auch
die Bauarbeiter sagen jetzt schon das
ist ganz kommunikativ hier man sieht
sich plötzlich gegenseitig ja aber das
Problem was sie vergessen in Deutschland
sind die Nachbarn dann auch häufig
deutsche
Dortmund hier gibt es noch echte
Malocher warum ich dann hier bin weiß
ich zwar auch nicht aber auf dem Bau
können sie ja heutzutage jeden
gebrauchen er Salewski kann losgehen
kann losgehen
gebaut werden oder ja das ist wunderbar
und wie läuft's hier gerade aktuell zum
Glück jetzt mittlerweile gut hat ja auch
nur knapp 14 Jahre gedauert bis los
geht's
warum hat 14 Jahre gedauert der Rat der
Stadt hat irgendwann beschlossen dass
sie gebaut werden soll ein sogenannten
aufstellungsverschluss gemacht und dann
kam die Bedenkenträger aus allen Ecken
und sagten es könnte zu laut sein die
Feuerwehr könnte nicht reinkommen wir
haben möglicherweise im Umweltprobleme
und rund ist die Fragen die da
aufgeworfen wurden alle beantwortet
worden waren ab 14
Jahren wurden ja 2010 auf die
Bauvorschriften deutlich vereinfacht was
hat sich da geändert
die Dämmung sind zum Beispiel wieder ein
bisschen dünner geworden und das ganze
baugenehmungsverfahren hat sich ein
bisschen feiern verändert und
vereinfacht was müsste man in ihrer
Meinung nach ändern damit das besser ist
die regulieren Wurzel allen übelst ist
eigentlich viel zu viele Regeln wir
schützen uns vor allem möglichen
Lärmschutz Schallschutz Brandschutz
schützen schützen nur bis wir dann
geprüft haben und gestempelt haben und
festgestellt haben dass wir genügend
geschützt sind die Prozesse dauern halt
ziemlich lange wie lange dauert denn so
eine Baugenehmigung mit den Niederlanden
drei Monate ist eine gute Zeit drei
Monate ja was ist denn der große Vorteil
wenn man hier in den Niederlanden baut
was man jetzt zum Beispiel sieht das
alles gleichzeitig passiert also da wird
schon geklingelt werden oben noch keine
Fenster drin sind das macht das Bauen
schon schneller ja wie ist es in
Deutschland da kommt eins nach dem
anderen ja auch häufig weil es sehr
unterschiedliche Firmen sind die gar
nicht unter einem Namen oder unter einem
Dach arbeiten und die natürlich wenn sie
dann kommen auch frei waren wünschen
[Musik]
ich finde die Baustelle ganz gut was ich
allerdings noch besser finde wenn man
diese hässliche komische Wand hier
abreißen würde was soll das die schützt
die Menschen von nicht vorhandenem
lärmen des benachbarten Gewerbegebiets
ach die haben sie erst gebaut oder was
natürlich
für knappe 7 Millionen Euro haben wir
hier ein Kilometer Wand hingestellt
ja sie haben ein Kilometer Wand hier
hingestellt für 7 Millionen Euro alles
gut bei Ihnen oder ja
warum was soll das Lärmschutz ist was
ganz wichtiges also gesunde
Wohnverhältnisse heißen in der Nacht hat
man einen halben Meter vor dem Fenster
draußen nicht mehr als 45 DBA
Schalldruck oder darf man haben so wenn
es Gewerbe Lärm ist wenn es jetzt zum
Beispiel Straßenverkehrslärm wäre
dürften es 55 dB sein
da jetzt die Laster von der öffentlichen
Straße hier auf dem privates Grundstück
fahren lassen Gewerbegrundstück ist
werden sie in dem Moment wo sie über die
Grenze fahren ungesund weil dann werden
sie Gewerbe lernen um die Dimension mal
zu verstehen 70 Quadratmeter Wohnung
wird durch das Ding bei einer sehr
konservativen Verzinsung 28 € teurer
jeden Monat ein Leben lang
also es ist ja schon und gut dass man
hier schneller und günstiger baut aber
dafür haben die Holländer ja gar kein
Trittschallschutz in ihren Wohnungen na
das stimmt ja so nicht ne dass sie
keinen Trittschallschutz haben das ist
immer die Frage wie sorge ich für einen
ausreichenden Schallschutz für die
Bewohnerinnen und Bewohner was
ausreichend ist das ist eigentlich die
Standorte Frage als wie ich dann
technisch löse dass wir wieder anfangen
darüber zu diskutieren ob man sich
vielleicht doch ein bisschen gegenseitig
hören darf natürlich hören wir den
Nachbarn und es ist vielleicht mal sogar
ganz schön zu wissen dass er da ist
warum das jetzt im Neubau nicht
vielleicht krank machen soll oder das
ein Grund wäre
mein Auftraggeber zu verklagen weil ich
jetzt plötzlich meine Nachbarn höre das
erschließt sich mir ganz häufig nicht
ich habe dem Amt am Anfang gesagt ja
wieso wenn es den Leuten zu laut ist
unsere Fenster zu machen wir bauen ja
energetisch sehr wertvoll ist über eine
Lüftungsanlage drin das heißt also ich
muss gar kein Fenster öffnen ja und wenn
das Fenster zu ist drei Scheiben
Verglasung Klimaschutz und so ist auch
leise ja und ja aber der lernpegel wird
nicht in der Wohnung gemessen wo der
Mensch gesund wohnen wo soll sondern
draußen davor aber das so im Regelwerk
steht ja dreifach verglast ist hier
eigentlich auch der Standard das ist
immer in diesen Neubauten auch noch so
dass wir versuchen viel Glas als eine
Art Qualität für die Wohnung zu
realisieren ne viel Licht in der Wohnung
in Deutschland haben wir dann sofort
Angst da mit dem Glas kommt auch die
Wärmer rein kannst dann dass wir
Deutschen immer Angst haben viel sehr
sehr viel Angst die Holländer können
sagen in Rotterdam am Hafen finden wir
es schön tolles Ambiente lieber
Bauträger bau mir meine Wohnung da
direkt ans Hafen Becken ich will mir das
muntere Geschehen angucken aber warum
sind wir Deutschen hier so dass wir
immer so geschützter müssen wir brauchen
Regeln und was ist denn da warum warum
die Frage stelle ich mir seit ich
angefangen bin zu arbeiten und schon ein
paar Jahrzehnte her ich weiß es nicht
[Musik]
und es begab sich zu einer Zeit als der
Bebauungsplan noch in Bearbeitung war
kam ein Gutachter und sollte feststellen
wie laut der Lernenden ist jetzt von
hinterher von den bananengern genau und
dann hat er sich mit seinem Campingstuhl
neben den unter den Baum gesetzt in der
Nacht und hat sein Mikro in die Luft
gehalten und sein Messgerät
erzählt um 5:34 Uhr hat er ein heftigen
Ausschlag ist aber was passiert ist und
bananenlaster gekommen Lösung
aufgegangen
jetzt ernsthaft ja natürlich ernsthaft
also meine Fantasie reicht nicht um mir
solche Geschichten einfallen zu lassen
das ist schon echt passiert wo sind die
Stellplätze fürs Auto
man hat kein Auto mehr wir haben unter
der Erde eine kleine Tiefgarage 40
Stellplätze und da kommen eigentlich nur
Carsharing Angebote rein also
private Auto braucht man Amsterdam
wirklich nicht
und wir sind hier in dem Gebäude wo
ungefähr 250 Wohnungen entstehen
40 Stellplätze dann kann man sich so ein
bisschen ausrechnen in Deutschland
müssten wir den Tiefgarage für 250 PKW
bauen
[Musik]
wunderbare Vokabeln im deutschen
Bauwesen Doppel
kopfbolzenhorizontal staubmaschine habe
ich bei meiner letzten Werks besichtigen
ich weiß ich doch nicht sagen
und haben sie das mit dem Graffiti
gemacht dass das schöner aussieht nein
die Künstler habe ich engagiert die
waren teuer weil das deswegen ist es so
schön geworden ganz alleine und während
der Nacht was ist denn jetzt das
Besondere an den Treppenstufen das hört
man doch immer die holländischen
Treppenstufen in den Niederlanden können
wir eigentlich alle ganz gut treffen
rauf und runter gehen die eine ganze
Ecke steiler sind in Deutschland ohne
uns gleich die Haxen zu brechen und das
spart natürlich Platz und macht zum
Beispiel auch andere Arten von
Treppenhäusern wirtschaftlich die dazu
führen dass wir zwei Rettungswege in
einem Treppenhaus kombinieren können
weswegen wir dann für den Brandschutz
viel geringere Anforderungen haben man
kommt direkt in einem Treppenhaus über
zwei unabhängige Routen nach unten und
dann brauche ich nicht mehr im Garten
diese großen Feuerwehr Aufstellflächen
zum Beispiel aber das ist den Deutschen
nicht zuzumuten eine steile Treppe zu
gehen nein das wollen wir nicht zu guten
natürlich hat es einen gewissen Komfort
aber vielleicht will ich das bisschen
Platz letztendlich auch nicht zur
Verfügung habe lieber in meinem
Wohnzimmer haben vielleicht sogar besser
aufgehoben aber wissen Sie wie viele
Niederländer im Jahr sterben weil sie
bekifft eine Treppe runterfallen nein
ich würde Titten null
[Musik]
und wieso wurde dann keine
Lärmschutzwand um diesen unglaublich
lauten Vogel gebaut das muss ich ja hier
als Deutscher mal feststellen gibt's da
keine Regel oder was natürlich nicht der
Vogel hat ja keine Gewerbe Erlaubnis
natürlich mein Fehler boah ist das
geräumig hier können zum Beispiel eine
schöne Kommode hin und hier noch so ein
tolles Bild ja hast du recht und und
hier hier kommen die weiteren Videos hin
und hier da könnt ihr den Kanal
abonnieren mit wem redest du weiter okay
echt viel Potenzial hier ja genau oder
hier das Bild
obwohl das besser hier das Bild und da
die Kommode